hi my name is canon drew I'm a global
shaper from the M the bath hub I'm just
coming back from the session on building
India's risk resilience it is a very
good session because this topic revolved
around creating resilient practices to
upcoming risks that are posed to India
and I believe that every risk in itself
is an opportunity to develop and there
are a lot of interesting ideas that
floated around the room in understanding
what could be done to create better
management and governance systems to
mitigate the upcoming risks I thought it
was a brilliant idea to bring all the
different perspectives in one room and
trying to create ideas and innovations
for the future so I'm I really enjoyed
it and I look forward to more sessions